die SEC die Schlichtung als «reines
wäre die jüngsten Krawalle Umbaus ja
klar dass man etwas will man natürlich
nicht von mir allenfalls Familie
Nicola warnte er
coole Sache
welche denn erstmal auch Prozent gut
dass du alles was tun trotz dann nicht
machen
dass sie die Sache
in Prozenten Holst
nun tun was er sage Kollaboalbum
Flächen mehr und das kann man sehr
Modern wir Fragen uns normal sind
gibt es auch sicherlich die Jungs sind
halt alle an ihren eigenen pro Sachen
mit ihren eigenen Sachen Geschäfte
haben alle noch den Willen einiges zu
erreichen und das sehen lassen erstmal
unten wenn die alten Mann durchführen
damit sicherlich auch wieder kollabieren